DUBNYK LEAVE IT BEHIND FOR
SCANDELLA.
KICKED AWAY BY
GRANLUND WITH A BLOCK.
DUMBA OFF THE BOARD FOR
GRANLUND.
BLUES ARE YEAR.
THAT'S WHY THEY EXTENDED HIM
THIS SUMMER.
>> SHATT ABOUT MANAGING HIS
CONFIDENCE.
>> HE'S HAD SO MANY PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER TELLING
HIM HOW GOOD HE IS.
UNTIL YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF
SUCCESS AT THE N WILD.
GRANLUND SETS UP.
KOIVU IN THE SLOT.
SUTER UP HIGH, BACK TO GRANLUND.
POMINVILLE DOWN LOW FOR
MINNESOTA.
WILD GET ANOTHER POWER PLAY
GOAL.
>> FOURTH GOAL OF THE SEASON FOR
ZACH PARISE, WHO SCORED 33 FOR
MINNESOTA LAST YEAR, FOURTH MOST
IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
THE WILD HAVE THEIR SECOND NOT S
COYLE.
MIGHT HAVE HIT HIM IN THE BODY.
>> Referee: INTERFERENCE ON
THE GOAL.
>> HERE IS CANNOT CHALLENGE WHEE
PUCK WENT IN CLEANLY BUT HE CAN
CHALLENGE WHETHER OR NOT THERE
WAS INTERFERENCE.
>> ALLEN, WILL HAVE TO SEE
THEY HAVE TO DECIDE IF, AFTER
LOOKING AT IT, THEY THINK THERE
IS A BETTER CALL.
>> Referee: AFTER VIDEO
REVIEW, FALL ON THE ICE IS
LEHTERA TIED UP BY SPURGEON.
44 POINTS IN HIS ROOKIE SEASON
LAST YEAR.
POMINVILLE TAKES IT AWAY FOR
MINNESOTA.
HE DEFINITELY HAS A NOSE FOR IT
IN THIS GAME.
>> WE ARE FIVE SKATERS A SIDE
WITH THE WILD ON TOP BY TWO.
STEEN ACROSS TO SHATTENKIRK.
TARASENKO BACK TO STEEN, THAT
JUST WIDE.
SHATTENKIRK WITH IT.
TARASENKO FIRES, S
>> STASTNY WINS THE DROP.
CLOSING SECONDS IN ST. PAUL.
DUBNYK AT THE HORN MAKES HIS
30TH FAITH O